At this point, you should have
successfully made your first network
request, but let's say,
I want to load a different image.
Specifically, let's say I want to load
an image that uses HTTP instead of
HTTPS.
Let's switch the URL and
rerun our project.
Now when we launch the app,
we see this error.
It says, App Transport Security has
blocked cleartext HTTP resource
load since it's insecure.
Temporary exceptions can be configured
in your app's Info.plist file.
What's this all about?
Well, it has to do with Apple's
new security feature called
App Transport Security or ATS.
ATS helps our apps be more secure
by forcing them to abide by certain
security standards and as we can see
in this little documentation, one such
standard is the recommendation to use
HTTPS exclusively, but what's HTTPS?
Well, it's like HTTP, but
with an added layer of security.
We'll talk about it more later
in this course, but for now,
just know that HTTPS helps ensure
that the data we send back and
forth across the network is more secure.
So, does this mean that we
can't use things that use HTTP?
Not exactly.
We can actually enable the use of HTTP
in our apps by changing some settings in
the Info.plist file.
This is what was recommended
in the debugger.
So, let's go to the Info.plist file.
Here at the top, let's click the plus
sign and add a new key value pair.
Start typing app transport and
select App Transport Security Settings.
This should automatically default
to a dictionary value and
we can add additional
settings to allow HTTP.
Click the arrow to expand the ATS
settings and then click the plus and
the setting we'll want to use
is called Allow Arbitrary Loads.
This is a Boolean value and
we'll set it to YES.
Setting this to YES is like saying, yes,
I want to allow any HTTP request for
my app.
Now we can actually be more specific and
configure settings that are like saying,
I want HTTP request, but
only for a specific domain.
For instance, .com and
I won't show that now, but
I'll post a how to link in the
instructor notes, if you're interested.
With these settings changed,
let's try running our project, nice.
There we go.
Our request works and there's no error.
There's one more thing that
I want to say about ATS.
As app developers, we may run into
situations where the data we want to
access over the network only uses HTTP.
So, how do we follow Apple's
guidelines and try to move to HTTPS?
Is there anything that we can do?
Well, if you find yourself
in that situation,
it's somewhat out of your hands.
The switch from HTTP to HTTPS is
something that the individual or
company running the server where you
access the data is responsible for.
So I'd recommend getting
in touch with them,
encouraging them to upgrade
their security standards.
If they're unable to upgrade to HTTPS,
you may also consider using a different
server or resource all together.
Whatever the case, the security of
data should always be top priority.
Otherwise, users may not be
willing to download your apps.